thanks madison you know to go up to the
lodge you have to pass by the resort
here in mount charleston i was told
today that the two of them always had
some friendly competition but today they
put all of that aside to help their
neighbors in need
phones have been ringing nonstop at the
resort at mount charleston hotel staff
are trying to accommodate as many people
as they can especially brides that had
their big day planned at the lodge one
possibly for tomorrow the resort is
willing to take in that bride as well as
hosting their parties that were already
booked so far they got calls from 50
brides that were hoping to have their
wedding at the lodge the general manager
says they're overwhelmed but willing to
help our phones went down that's how
many we got
so we just got them back up answering as
fast as we can the head chef of the
resort has been making sure the first
responders had lunch while working on
the fire they sent dozens of boxed
lunches up the mountain we're just happy
to be able to accommodate you know our
community up here on the mountain we're
honored to provide meals for our first
responders
and
for everyone else that wants to come
here and enjoy nice meals the resort
also served as a place for fire crews to
take a break
now that the resort has to accommodate
more events they are hosting a job fair
here tomorrow for those displaced
workers at the lodge it's going to be
from 10 a.m to 1 p.m reporting from
mount charleston victoria saha live
local now